bonsoir une explosion nucléaire
voilà un scénario qui s'est déjà répété
plusieurs fois sur notre planète mais
que nous n'avons pas encore réussi à
éliminer de notre réalité
depuis les premiers essais nucléaires
dans les années 40 mais surtout après
les plus récents accidents des centrales
de fukushima et tchernobyl
il nous est devenu impossible de nier
les risques associés à la manipulation
de matériaux radioactifs
cette manipulation qui est nécessaire
pour la production d'énergie nucléaire
alors 16 accidents peuvent très vite se
transformer en un énorme problème de
contamination tant au niveau de
l'environnement que de l'homme la
contamination est enrayée à ces
radionucléides ces petites particules
radioactives toxiques qui vont être
disséminées tout autour de nous très
facilement après une explosion et ces
particules vont pouvoir me contaminer
assez facilement par différentes voies
comme l'inhalation c'est à dire si nous
respirons une atmosphère contaminés ou
par ingestion si nous consommons de
l'eau ou de la nourriture contaminée ou
alors à travers des blessures ces
radionucléides en question ce sont des
éléments chimiques radioactifs comme le
plutonium l'uranium qui vont causé de
nombreux dégâts une fois incorporé dans
l'organisme
ils vont se déposer dans les eaux le
foie les reins et commencer à générer
des hausses rapides de taux de cancer et
donc se saucer dépôt de radionucléides
que mon équipe et moi-même cherchant à
réduire en développant ce qu'on appelle
des molécules qui l'attend
pour cela nous nous sommes inspirés de
la biochimie du fer le faire mais pas
radioactifs
c'est un autre élément le chimique qui
lui nous est essentielle nous avons tous
besoin de faire pour des fonctions
vitales élémentaires comme la
respiration par exemple et les
micro-organismes aussi ont besoin de
faire quand une bactérie pathogénique
nous envahit pendant une infection
elle va vouloir se procurer notre faire
pour survivre
et donc elle va envoyer ses petites
molécules qui marche comme des crabes
avec des pinces qui cherche le faire
s'agrippe offert formica dessus et vont
ramener le métal à la bactérie alors
nous avons copié cette stratégie puisque
nous avons aussi développé des crabes
mais eux ils aiment le plutonium et donc
c'est en modifiant la structure de ces
molécules quelles attentes que l'on
change les pinces et que l'on va cibler
avec beaucoup plus de spécificité
les radionucléides qui vont alors formé
un complexe plutôt stable et qui va être
excrété plus rapidement et plus
facilement alors super on a une molécule
qui l attendent qui marche
mais en fait le plus gros du travail
reste à faire puisque imaginer un
scénario de contamination il va lui
falloir être capable de distribuer cette
molécule de manière massive est facile
mais aussi être sûr qu'il n'a pas
d'effets secondaires et donc pour
acquérir le statut de médicament nos
composés doit vous répondre à plusieurs
critères
ces critères c'est de pouvoir être
produit à grande échelle de pouvoir être
administré facilement c'est à dire par
voie orale par exemple ou alors
s'assurer que le connaît leur devenir
dans l'organisme pour savoir s'il ya une
toxicité éventuelle et donc mon équipe
de recherche a passé les huit dernières
années a à faire en sorte que notre
meilleur molécules répondent à ces
critères et nous en sommes arrivés à ce
produit
alors ça brille pas le noir ça ressemble
à n'importe quel gélules que vous pouvez
trouver en pharmacie
c'est pas très impressionnant mais nous
avons fait tous les tests pour
déterminer l'efficacité de ce produit
et ça marche et nous sommes enfin prêts
à démarrer nos essais cliniques chez
l'homme alors rassurez-vous nous
n'allons pas faire d' essai clinique
contrôlé ou en contamine des personnes
avec du plutonium exprès juste pour
vérifier que notre produit marche
non nous allons juste voir si ce produit
nous avons essayé de comprendre la
pharmacologie nous allons voir s'il ya
par exemple des effets secondaires chez
l'homme et une fois que ces tests seront
finis nous serons enfin en mesure de
répondre à une contamination nucléaire
bien que on espère bien sûr ne jamais
être confronté à une telle situation
c'est quand même temps ironique de
développer un produit qu'on espère ne
jamais utiliser
c'est un peu n'importe quoi au niveau
business book
aucune compagnie parmi celles ci
aucune compagnie compagnies
pharmaceutiques le auraient voulu
dépenser autant d'argent que nous passer
autant de temps que nous a développé en
fait le produit alors nous avons sombre
lentement mais grâce au soutien de
gouvernement d'organismes
gouvernementaux et nous avons vraiment
bénéficié la la conjecture actuelle
alors quelqu'un at il vu les dernières
nouvelles de corée du nord ce matin
ce scénario n'est pourtant pas nouveau
nous sommes en septembre 2016
et pourtant cette photo que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure les essais date
des années 40
les premières bombes atomiques ont été
relâchés dans les années 40
depuis que l'on connaît que l'on a
découvert le plutonium que l'on connaît
les effets néfastes de la contamination
radioactive des chercheurs du monde
entier s'activent pour découvrir un
traitement alors moi je ne suis pas
arriver les mains dans les poches avec
mon idée brillante
j'ai bénéficié bien sûr de deux systèmes
d'éducation hors pair en france et aux
états unis mais surtout quand j'ai
commencé à travailler sur ce projet une
jeune française fraîchement diplômés
dans un gros la boîte américain le mât
mise de pair avec une de mes mentors qui
avait à l'époque 87 ans et donc avec mon
directeur de laboratoire
elle avait elle avait travaillé sur ce
projet depuis depuis des années depuis
les années 50
et elle avait testé et développé des
centaines de molécules et ça fait
beaucoup de sourires mais en revanche
ils n'avaient pas encore franchi toutes
les étapes pour passer d'une molécule
sur la paillasse de laboratoire à un
produit qu'on peut commercialiser
parce que comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
ses études il y en a beaucoup à faire
dans le plein de domaines différents et
il faut beaucoup d'énergie pour par
exemple avait cherché des financements
pour collaborer avec des équipes
extérieures des équipes internationales
et donc ces chercheurs y ont tout appris
mais il m'a aussi fait confiance pour
prendre ce projet en moins une confiance
parfois sans limite qui m'a vraiment
permis d'avancer plus vite et qui m'a
permis de contribuer à cet effort en
pourtant mes propres points de vue qui
étaient le plus souvent différent du
leur et donc maintenant que je dirige ma
propre équipe de recherche c'est quelque
chose que je donne force et me rappeler
que mon expertise n'est pas universel
qu'il faut faire place au nouveau venu
même s'ils n'ont pas le même parcours
scolaire que moi le même âge la même
origine les mêmes points de vue
ma responsabilité maintenant c'est de
continuer nos projets de les renouveler
aussi mais surtout de faire la place aux
nouveaux venus de leur fournir toutes
les ressources techniques et de leur
laisser le champ libre pour qu'ils
puissent prendre leurs propres risques
leur propre initiative pour pouvoir
pousser l'innovation plus loin alors
pensez à ces particules radioactives
elles ne font pas la différence entre
français et américains
elles ne font pas les différences entre
femmes et hommes elles ne font pas la
différence entre vieux et jeunes et donc
peut-être nous pourrions être un peu
comme l ai essayé d'évoluer vers un
modèle multi social multi-culturel
multigénérationnel pour que nous
puissions nous attaquer à ces vieux
problème pour que nous puissions
développer de nouvelles technologies et
surtout apporter des solutions efficaces